everyone i'm samuel leeds right now i'm
standing in middlesbrough i bought a lot
of houses in middlesbrough and generally
up north
from 2009 to 2017 in my own
personal name this was before they
changed the tax rules
now it's more tax efficient to owning a
company but it doesn't make sense to
move it from your personal name to a
company
so i'm keeping all the houses in my
personal name however this house
my wife wants me to sell this house
because
well i'll tell you why i mean it was an
asset i did i used to love this house um
me and darwin my man have just looked
around it now darwin do you like it
i love it he loves it i love it i want
to live in it you wouldn't live in it
okay so
basically here was the pattern of this
property so we bought this a few years
back
bought it for fifty six thousand pounds
to be honest i was gassed
i was gassed here's what i was guessed i
mean what do you reckon
56 grand for a house in this area not
bad it's not bad
the rent on this place i was renting
this house out for five
to five so if you think about the maths
there
bought it for 56 000 pounds put down 25
percent
what's that 56 000 pounds 25
that means that we put down a deposit of
14
grand 14 grand so put down 14 grand
i think it was actually about 16 000 in
all um
then the mortgage is 56 000 minus 14
grand
42 grand we've got a 42 000 pound debt
on this place
mortgage payments are three percent so
we're paying per month
we're paying 105 pounds per month you're
paying 105 pounds a month on the
interest
you're renting the bad boy out for 550
you're making a nice little profit every
single month
so that was great however what happened
was
the tenant that was in here paying 550
moved out left the place looking
yeah okay we bought it in excellent
condition and then
when we went to remarket the property
the laying agent said
to be honest you know you're probably
only talking 450 475
so we put a tenant in here paying a bit
less our monthly
profit was less dude would you wear this
jacket
do you want it you want this jacket
until i
actually genuinely last night we slept
in a hotel
i genuinely was going to suggest that we
sleep here instead of a hotel
now i'm in here i mean maybe darwin
could sleep in here
uh i don't think i'll pass but so so
anyway so this property is been making
us a few japan a month last few years
um we bought it for 56 000.
now as you can see it's not trashed
we can clear this out but someone
offered to buy this house someone said
they'll buy it
um the agent got in touch and said
someone must have bought
58 and a half thousand pounds and and
i'm thinking
nah i want to wait for capital
appreciation
but we decided let's say we my wife
decided
that we'd just sell it we'd get our
money back
would you like a cup of tea by the way
darwin i'm right thank you are you sure
you're
sure
oh man that smells they sure don't want
a cup of tea they've got some juice in
the front if you want it
they got some juice there if you want it
i'm good man i'm good you know what i'm
protected by the blood of jesus i could
drink this
um i wouldn't i wouldn't would you not
i wouldn't
oh no we're gonna sell this house
we're gonna get that 14 grand back
plus two and a half thousand which to be
honest it's just gonna get swallowed up
in fees
yeah we've been making a few hundred
pounds a month on this house okay
i'd much rather buy this house for fifty
six thousand
rent it for four fifty five fifty
whatever
then buy a house in the midlands for 150
grand
you're gonna get the same rent the
correlation of the rent is kind of the
same
you know the correlation of the rent's
kind of the same so
buy low went high however we're gonna
sell it get our 14 grand back
and we're going to put that into getting
planning permission
on a piece of land which is going to
make us six figures so
you know what i think with property you
win some you lose some come on out let's
go you win some you lose some
this house is average i don't really
like it that much
average and uh we're gonna sell it
it's average house i don't know anyway
why did i do this video because i want
to document not only the exciting stuff
i don't just want to document me
making a hundred thousand pounds on a
house or doing a big flip also i want to
show you some of the more vanilla
vitalettes
this house is very vanilla it's very
average i've lost the keys man
you just had them i'm just i can't i
can't not lock the door because someone
a thief could come in and steal
the lucas i doubt it thief could come in
and steal the lucas side but anyway so
yeah i just want to show you the real
and here's the thing as well most of my
properties i only my personal name
so this house only my personal name most
of my houses only my personal name
some of them are really good some of
them are like oh my gosh they've doubled
in value
or i've rented them out as a hmo and i'm
getting a thousand pound a month off
them they're amazing
some of them are decent and some of them
are just meh you know
some of them are not so good and that's
always going to happen it's not about
owning more houses
you know i know people that own 100
houses but they don't really make any
money
it's all about making money and you know
i mean last year we turned over just shy
of 10 mil with a 20
net profit last year i made millions of
pounds last
week i made 200 000 on a property deal
you know so i'm winning but then not
everything is always
absolutely rosy people sometimes tell me
i make it look too easy
i only show the good stuff so i started
showing one of my average vanilla
promises you want to see more subscribe
subscribe
right here what are you waiting for
do it and you want to see more videos
check our whole playlist right here
thanks peace see you next time
do it
you